Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David
P. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: Hey, David,
This is Mike from Sacramento. I just want
to say, like when I like your show a lot to
the last four family gatherings that I've had,
like my right wing relatives, all they talk about,
all they talk about is like transgender
stuff, like how much they hate the, you know,
the different, you know, whatever. There's like
one one transgender woman that bids people in like
swimming and that's all they talk about. That's
the most important thing in the entire world. Yep.
That in like, black mermaids and black people
shouldn't be in any movies, basically. So I think.
Speaker 1: Listen, folks, Santa Claus
is white and mermaids are white. Why
can't these jokesters understand that.
Speaker 4: Like this next election,
we need to be prepared for any response that we
can do regarding those types of things. Yeah,
I think like Chris Christie, even though I agree,
he does sound pretty smart to me and to you.
They the Republicans don't care about that stuff
anymore. They don't care about taxes or foreign
policy. All they care about is culture wars. So
I think we have to have good responses for that
stuff. My response to them was it's like they're
saying, oh, we're we're concerned that transgender
people are just going into women's dressing rooms
to rape them. Well, guess what? Donald Trump went
into a dressing room dressed as a man and he raped
somebody. So they can't even they're using that.
Speaker 1: As sexually assaulted. Hold on a
second. Hold on a sec. Let's be clear. Now,
the caller is I mean, that's crazy. And it is
incredible that these are the conversations.
You know, at one point, the sort of Thanksgiving
conversations were very politically stressful,
but they were about like tax policy and foreign
policy. Now it's about black mermaids. And that
is that is a really crazy commentary about where
we are today. Folks, we've got a bonus show coming
up right after this show. Make sure you're
subscribed. Join Pacman dot com to get instant
access to the bonus show. We've got an incredible
week of shows coming up. I will be at a wedding on
the West Coast. We've got a great cast of villains
and then I'm going to be back with you so strongly
so strongly, folks, on Monday. Please be nice
to the guest hosts, at least to their face.
Okay. You can email me later and complain,
but please be nice to their face. We'll see
you on the bonus show. And then everything
just continues throughout the rest of the.